yeah I really why is it breaking in the
internet it's just ramen we're getting
ready to taste Kylie Jenner's ramen
recipe she snapchatted it recently to
all of her fans us the two of us I think
Kylie is the voice of the new generation
I'm aware of what's going on with that I
keep up with them but I don't watch the
show I just know it's not that I really
hate the Kardashians is that I'm
completely confused by them you won't
believe what Kylie puts in her ramen I
look at it I'm like this is what me and
all my Asian friends have been doing for
forever I don't know a damn thing about
the ramen that Kylie makes I know about
the room that I make I thought Oh sour
cream in there I thought my feet are in
line with ramen literally it was just a
picture and she said I add garlic and
egg and butter to my ramen doesn't tell
us how much doesn't tell us like why
poop doesn't show us how to do it and
we're all doing it bow down to Kylie
there's a lot of power if I came to your
house and you sent me this [ __ ] I've
like what the hell it looks like
something they would get at the best
Chinese takeout store looks like
something my dog coughed up and it
tastes like popcorn and because of the
butter it's a good face it could you
know what our stuff the garlic powder is
doing a lot of work he's really salty
well that's us nobody can pack it in the
ramen do you think she adds seasoning in
it she's using that pack and I know that
packet I love that I find all that
packet it's the perfect amount of garlic
then again we don't know how much she
puts in it so maybe we're the geniuses
she has finished her bowl look at this
look at this America it's real good to
see all of it I don't understand why
people have not put stuff in the ramen
before if people have put stuff in the
Robin for making a big deal that's so
sad look at this point though she could
literally just throw anything together
into a bowl and it would go by wrong and
it would sell I'm in prices are gonna go
up now people buy more ramen all right
that you should get research on that we
need to use Kylie for
things to get more food out there
there's a bunch of rich teenagers in
Calabasas eating ramen noodle the
kardashian-jenner kids fountain really
what is this incredibly exotic this is
like the most relatable thing about her
so far the fact that she eats ramen and
so do we
that's it that's all we have in common
who knew she would be the one that's
like gonna become the next Kim you know
no one saw it coming I saw it coming